write 7 over 4 as a mixed number so
right now it's an improper fraction 7 is
larger than 4. let's write it as a mixed
number so first i'm just going to show
you a fairly straightforward way of
doing it and then we're going to think
about a little bit about what it
actually means so to figure out what 7
over 4 represents as a mixed number let
me write it in different colors so this
is going to be equal to let me
the easiest way i do it you say well you
take 4 you divide 4 into seven so you
divide four
into seven
four into seven so four if we're dealing
with fourths four goes into seven a
total of one time
four goes into seven a total of let me
do this in another color
a total of one time one times four is
four
and then what is our remainder seven
minus four is three so if we wanted to
write this in plane well let me just do
the problem then we'll think about what
it means in a second so you see that
four goes into seven one time
so you have one hole here you have one
whole and then how much do you have left
over well you have three left over
you have three left over
and that comes from right over there
that is the remainder when you divide
four into seven three left over but it's
three of your four
or three fourths left over so that's the
way we just converted it from an
improper fraction to a mixed number now
it might seem a little bit like voodoo
what i just did i divided 4 into 7 it
goes one time and then the remainder is
3. so i got 1 and three fourths but why
does that make sense why does that
actually make sense so let's draw
fourths let's draw literally seven
fourths and maybe it'll become
maybe it'll become clear
so let's do a little square as a fourth
so i'm going to do it
let's say i have a square like that
and that is
1 4.
now let's think about what seven of
those mean so let me copy and paste that
copy
and then paste it so that's
so here i have two one-fourths or you
could say i have two fourths
now i have three one-fourths
now i have four one-fourths now this is
a hole right i have four one-fourths
this is a hole
so let me start on another hole so now i
have five
now i have six one-fourths
and now i have seven one-fourths
now what does this look like so all i
did is i rewrote seven fourths or seven
one-fourths i just kind of drew it for
you
now what does this represent well i have
four-fourths here so this is four over
four
this right here is three over four
notice seven over four is four fourths
with three fourths left over
so let me write it this way seven over
four
is four fourths with three fourths left
over now what is four fourths
what is four fourths
four fourths is one whole so you have
one whole with three fourths left over
so you end up with one and three fourths
so that is the three-fourths part and
that is your one whole hopefully that
makes sense and hopefully you understand
why it connects because you say well how
many holes do you have when you're when
you're dividing in the four into the
seven and getting the one you're
essentially saying how many holes
how many
how many so the number
of holes or you know you can imagine the
number of whole pies and then how many
pieces do we have left over well we have
three pieces and each piece is a fourth
so we have three fourths left over so we
have one whole pie and three pieces
which are each a fourth left over